Дедалі більше українців рятуються від війни, котру розпочала Російська Федерація в Україні.
В Європі очікують на декількох мільйонів українських біженців.
Для них Рада Євросоюзу домовилася активувати тимчасовий захист.
Згідно з директивою Ради ЄС, українці, які рятуються від війни,
отримають тимчасовий захист в ЄС,
тобто їм буде надано дозвіл на проживання, і вони матимуть доступ до освіти, медицини та ринку праці.
Директиву розробили, щоб надати негайний захист українцям, які цього потребують,
а також уникнути перевантаження системи надання класичного притулку в державах-членах ЄС.
Комісія також запропонує оперативні рекомендації,
щоб допомогти прикордонникам держав-членів ЄС ефективно управляти прибуттям на кордон із Україною,
зберігаючи при цьому високий рівень безпеки.
Тимчасовий захист надає, зокрема, право на проживання, доступ до ринку праці,
медичних послуг і соціальної допомоги у країнах ЄС.
Для дітей та підлітків без супроводу тимчасовий захист надає право на законну опіку та доступ до освіти.
Переселенці з України також можуть привозити свої особисті речі без мит і своїх домашніх улюбленців.
Зазвичай на ввіз тварин у ЄС потрібно оформлювати багато різних документів. Цю процедуру спростять.
Окрім того, директива має сприяти спрощенню адміністративних процедур,
а також передбачить розподіл відповідальності між країнами ЄС за принципом солідарності.
Для цього створять так звану Платформу солідарності,
де країни ЄС обмінюватимуться даними щодо можливостей прийому українців.
Передбачається, що такі агенції ЄС, як Frontex, Агентство Європейського Союзу з питань притулку та Європол,
надаватимуть підтримку державам ЄС.
Ці права прив'язані не до всього ЄС, а до конкретної держави.
Для того, щоб ними користуватися, треба звернутися по дозвіл на проживання до органів влади,
які займаються питаннями тимчасового захисту.
В різних державах це можуть бути різні установи.
Там біженцям повинні видати документ, який зрозумілою їм мовою пояснюватиме їхніх статус і права.
Після отримання дозволу на проживання, подорожувати в інші країни Шенгену можна буде,
але за звичними для безвізу правилами: не більше 90 днів за пів року.
Це набір мінімальних стандартів.
Якщо ж якась держава Євросоюзу надає більшу та ширшу підтримку, то це лише вітається.
Захист зможуть отримати громадяни України, громадяни третіх країн, які мають посвідку на проживання в Україні,
та ті біженці, які шукали притулку в Україні.
Не підпадають під це правило ті, хто перебував в Україні короткостроково
й може безпечно повернутися до країни походження.
Їм можуть дозволити в'їзд до ЄС лише з метою транзиту.
Цей тимчасовий захист діятиме наразі один рік.
Якщо ситуація в Україні не зміниться на краще,
то дію директиви автоматично буде подовжено на шість місяців.
Така пролонгація можлива двічі.
Комісія може у будь-який час запропонувати Раді ЄС припинити тимчасовий захист,
якщо ситуація в Україні дозволятиме безпечне і тривале повернення громадян додому.